salut aujourd'hui je vous donne la
solution aux défis d'hier alors si vous
n'avez pas vu le défi d'hier regarder le
avant puisque là je donne la solution
vous ne pourrez vous chercher après la
solution va vous paraître un petit peu
tordu mal fonctionne à 100% j'ai
toujours réussi à me faire payer des
verres avec ce défi la pièce est mis
sous une tasse et vous affirmez que vous
allez pouvoir récupérer la pièce sans
toucher à la tasse la technique que
j'emploie est très simple je tape avec
ma main sous la table et je fais
semblant d'attraper la pièce comme au
travers en personne n'y croit je vous
rassure je garde le poing serré et je
dis à la personne c'est bon j'ai
récupéré la pièce elle est plus la tasse
peut vérifier les plus en dessous où tu
peux vérifier les plus en dessous
personne n'y croit il ya toujours
quelqu'un pour soulever la tasse pour
vérifier et là faut être prêt faut être
prêt à attraper la pièce à ce moment là
et une fois que vous l'avez attrapé vous
avez rempli votre défi et dire c'est bon
regarde j'ai attrapé la pièce sans
toucher la tasse exactement comme je
l'avais dit oui c'est tordu mais ça
fonctionne et ça permet d'avoir des
verres gratuits et de réussir un défi
est maintenant
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui comme aujourd'hui
on est dimanche je me suis dit cette
énigme numéro 3 pouvait changer un petit
peu nous allons parler de francs quilez
et claude vous ne connaissez pas ces
trois personnes franck will et claude et
pourtant franck le frère de will
will est le frère de claude et pourtant
claude n'est pas le frère de franck je
répète frank et le frère de will will
est le frère de claude mais claude n'est
pas le frère de franck comment ça se
fait il y a comme toujours une solution
très simple et très logique
vous la trouverez j'en suis sûre ce
dimanche si vous avez la réponse n'en
parlez pas dans les commentaires mais
plutôt mettez un pouce en l'air comme ça
ça nous permet de voir tout de suite le
pourcentage de personnes qui ont trouvé
la solution par rapport au nombre de
vues par les ans dans les commentaires
sans donner la solution je vous en
supplie profiter du soleil passe un
excellent et et n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir parce que
mentale blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an et rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
oui